how are you is the same not good that
happens sometimes every day same thing
the same thing every day so the root of
all suffering is our desire not to
suffer no one asked you Louie
[Music]
star not just did a puzzle only children
blue Magnus remember that word us into
dust thou shalt return puzzle brightener
I'm here got the puzzles seem to have
some luck on your flag
it's Ash Wednesday is that a problem no
not at all
as long as we don't have to share the
prize in the Pope competition I'm doing
it honey
I'm not asking you I'm telling you
you're so much more comfortable when
you're focusing on the puzzles as yon
he's using you everybody always uses you
and you let him I don't know why someone
like you would find me interesting
you're modest and strange and beautiful
and funny does that make me weird no
just different life is messy there's
nothing we can do to control anything
where's dinner I slave all day for this
family what's wrong with you
when you complete a puzzle you know that
you have made all the right choices
all right puzzlers on my count three two
[Music]
you gotta tell me everything I don't
have to tell you anything
it's the best thing I've ever done faith
ambition love what are the pursuits can
give you the kind of affection to
getting all the wrong pieces right
[Music]
you
[Music]
you